voici la première vidéo d'une série de
salles au sli un peu spéciaux l'idée
dans les prochains mois c'est de vous
donner les clés en à peu près cinq
minutes des programmes des différents
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
pour vous puissiez voir plus clair alors
je sais ce que vous allez me dire ouais
mais cyrus se sert à rien ce que tu fais
tous les pots a besoin dit poliment
ligne toute façon on peut très bien le
lire tout seul
ce à quoi je répondrai déjà encore une
fois personne n'est pas comme ça et en
plus les programmes des politiques en
ligne bas c'est un petit peu comme les
mises à jour des conditions générales de
sa fiat
tout le monde ya accès tout le monde
sait que c'est hyper important mais
personne ne les lit
je vais donc essayer de vous résumer ces
programmes sans porter de jugement en me
concentrant sur ce que chaque candidat
souhaite mettre en avant dans ce bois
l'idée c'est de garder à peu près la
même structure entre chaque vidéo et
malgré tout je vous encourage chaudement
à vous renseigner par vous même et aller
consulter les différents programmes des
candidats
ce n'est que comme ça que vous pourrez
avoir en tête l'intégralité de leurs
propositions
proposition que je ne pourrai
malheureusement pas couvrir en cinq
minutes et c'est très important pour
pouvoir prendre une décision d'avoir
toutes les informations
enfin dernière chose on ne parlera pas
non plus des différents scandales qui
peuvent être liés à chaque candidat
d'autres le font beaucoup mieux que moi
donc j'ai décidé de me concentrer sur le
programme uniquement et puisqu'on parle
de prise de décision et qu'il faut bien
commencer pas quelqu'un on va parler du
programme d'un homme qui a décidé que la
france n'avait plus le temps pour
l'indécision françois fillon son
programme c'est de redresser la france
lui redonner sa puissance redorer son
blason et pour ça faut commencer par
avoir une france compétitive face aux
autres pays en libérant l'économie
l'économie l'économie aille fillon ça
commence par une baisse des dépenses
publiques de 100 milliards en cinq ans
justement pour redresser le pays
alors comment on arrive à économiser 100
milliards eh bien il a plusieurs pistes
rétablir les 39 heures dans la fonction
publique plafonner et rendre dégressives
les allocations chômage et traquer
viadeo dit ce qui coûte cher et ne sert
à rien pour le supprimer ou le remplacer
par des actions en lequel ils croient
plus ils proposent aussi 40 milliards de
baisse des charges pour les entreprises
pour créer un big bang de l'emploi et 10
milliards d'allègements sociaux et
fiscaux pour les ménages
afin de dynamiser l'économie quitte à
les financer partiellement par une
hausse de la tva et veut globalement
supprimer tout ce qui empêche le privé
de s'épanouir et il ya un tas d'autres
mesures qui sont dans le but de libérer
cette économie comme supprimer les 35
heures pour le travailleur français plus
compétitifs instaurer un contrat de
travail avec des modalités de rupture
prédéfinis pour plus de flexibilité et
supprimer l' isf pour encourager la
réussite et le financement des
entreprises par des gens aujourd'hui
taxé après en partant du constat que
nous vivons de plus en plus âgés il
propose le recul de l'âge de la retraite
à 65 ans et l'unification de tous les
régimes de retraite à l'idée d'en
contrat et plus longtemps et cotisent
ont plus pour maintenir un meilleur
pouvoir d'achat sociale
dans cette même logique de redorer le
blason de la france on retrouve un set
de valeurs de la république française
il souhaite soutenir et promouvoir une
politique familiale forte en
rétablissant l'universalité des
allocations il ne touchera pas la loi
taubira sauf sur la question de
l'adoption
la pma procréation médicalement assistée
qui doit être réservé qu'aux couples
hétérosexuels infertiles et la gpa
gestation pour autrui qui doit être
interdite
kita propositionnelle à france au niveau
international il propose de positionner
la france en chef de file au niveau
mondial sur la lutte contre la
marchandisation du corps de la femme car
payé une femme pour qu'elle porte un
enfant pour autrui mais intolérable
je cite la laïcité est aussi pour
françois fillon l'une des valeurs les
plus importantes de la république est
selon lui elle a été mise à mal ces
dernières années il souhaite donc la
restaurer en permettant aux entreprises
va imposer un code de laïcité alors
salariée rendre le financement d islam
transparent et sanctionner les prêches
anti-français et les discours favorable
à la charia et au jihad l'écologie
toujours avec cette idée de rendre la
france compétitive lui redonner sa
position de superpuissance mondiale
françois fillon et pro nucléaire et
souhaite consolider la filière se
l'énergie permettant selon lui
aujourd'hui au front
c'est une indépendance énergétique à un
prix abordable il souhaite aussi prouver
qu'il est possible d'associer économie
et écologie en développant une filière
française des énergies renouvelables
pour faire de la france un champion du
secteur et la route à cela cependant son
souhait de protéger les espaces naturels
de la france et obtenir des résultats en
matière d'amélioration de la qualité de
l'air car même si pour la journaliste
ruth elkrief l'écologie semble être une
question de bobo la pollution
atmosphérique
reste la troisième cause de mortalité en
france c'est que sécurité redonner à la
france sa puissance ça passe aussi par
restaurer l'autorité de l'état et là on
a le droit de dépenser un peu d'argent
du coup on n'est plus là pour déconner
c'est tolérance zéro
il prévoit donc d'investir jusqu'à 2% du
pib à l'horizon 2025 pour améliorer la
condition des militaires investir 12
milliards d'euros dans la sécurité la
défense et la justice en créant au
passage seize mille places de prison en
plus pour que les peines puissent enfin
être plongée avec les terroristes même
combat on interdit le retour sur le
territoire français partis combattre
avec les terroristes à l'étranger et on
expulse de france tout moment ce qui
s'en approche
tolérance zéro et comme il n'ya pas de
petites réformes sécuritaires on
supprime les allocations aux familles
dont les enfants commettent des
manquements répétés
on sanctionne désormais systématiquement
toutes les infractions qui pourrissent
la vie des français et on accepte les
uniformes dans les établissements qui le
souhaitent et mes questions c'est la
même chose tolérance zéro j'arrête mais
vous avez l'idée un françois fillon
n'est pas homme associé
on met donc un terme à l'immigration
irrégulière en expulsant tous les
clandestins et on réduit l'immigration
légale à son strict minimum
ça ça passe par l'instauration de quotas
annuels d'immigration la réforme de la
procédure d'asile et du regroupement
familial et la mise en place de
statistiques ethniques et faire
désormais de la simulation la condition
sinequanone à la société française
donc retour aux valeurs restauration de
l'autorité de l'état et libération
l'économie vous connaissez maintenant la
formule de françois fillon pour
redresser la france et les grandes
lignes de son programme pour 2017
je vous mets dans la description un lien
vers son programme complet pour que vous
puissiez aller plus loin par vous même
et on se retrouve très vite pour le
prochain candidat
j'aime voir cette vidéo vous a plu cinq
minutes c'est très court seulement
d'être très synthétique mais le but ici
c'est peut-être pas toucher les gens qui
s'intéressent à la politique d'habitude
mais plutôt les autres 1 ceux qui s'en
sont désintéressés et avoue bas j'espère
que cette vidéo vous
rendu les choses un peu plus clair voilà
vous invite à me suivre sur facebook
twitter est un chat sa foi je parle à
tout le monde
n'hésitez pas à partager la vidéo est à
vous abonner pour ne pas rater les
prochaines un gros merci aux types
heures qui participent à cette mission
publique love peace now n'est pas
m'associer à ce que j'ai besoin
essentiel en même temps du coup c voilà
pour la vanne c'était l'humour